Jarrid you would you see that Facebook
is one of the most important social
networks out there it's the one to if
people are gonna choose and try to you
know not use all these different
products and kind of put themselves down
like didn't want your context I mean you
know I wouldn't look at sheer numbers of
people at standpoint from a personal
standpoint let's go above okay well I
think from a personal standpoint that
ship has sailed right I mean that's the
social network people are on you know
Aunt Sue excuse me
great Aunt Sue and her 72 years old is
rocking you know Facebook and finding
like her you know sweetheart from when
she was five years old and flying to
Oklahoma to like high-five him he needs
to calm down the cake stands though I
agree you know it's not angst and photos
I don't know you know but the fact that
matters is that is that from a business
standpoint I think Facebook pages are
very interesting you know I think you
know Twitter is a great platform it's
quick it's got a lot of value but what
Facebook pages allows and you know under
the vaynermedia umbrella that I live
with my brother and we do a lot of
consulting and strategy for brands it
has a lot of flexibility I mean you
could build a website on top of a
Facebook page I firmly believe that
customers are more comfortable with a
facebook URL so if you are a Pepsi or a
Ford or the National Hockey League when
you're running a commercial or using
traditional media and layering social on
top of it facebook.com slash NHL is
something consumers are a little bit
more comfortable to go to plus you can
you know do a lot of things on that
platform to interact their social graph
so I would say that Facebook pages in a
lot of ways for businesses is the most
necessity driven page because you can
actually do a lot of things you can code
on top of it and so yeah I think I think
it's a necessity I I think that um
Facebook in a lot of ways you know it's
tough to say they've won right cuz if
this was years ago and we were sitting
here talking about AOL and I would have
been like AOL won right and so I think I
think you got to be careful about those
things on the flip side nobody's ever
really I had a bunch of friends when the
whole privacy thing broke tell me that
they were gonna quit Facebook like Gary
you're into that stuff right you know
they're kind of telling me these are
like normal friends outside baseball
right and I was like yeah and they're
like I gotta tell you something cuz
maybe you can make one of those silly
videos I went to go quit Facebook and
I'm
last page it showed a picture like my
wife and my best friend it's amazing and
they said you know Thea you know we're
sad you're leaving but oh by the way
before you leave before you hit that
last button and you're leaving Facebook
we just want you to know that grandma
and and your best friend John and your
wife Sally you're gonna miss you a
Photoshop to tear on there okay and so
and so um and they couldn't choose
separate friends who don't know each
other because of the whole privacy thing
six months ago both let me know that
they did not quit Facebook and once you
map that social graph there's a lot of
interesting things that go on so I think
it there beast yeah what I mean do you
think that it's getting to a point where
they're kind of wet what Gary so there's
so much noise that it's tough to map
that social graph of it well I think I
think it's strange that like Facebook
has managed to very cleverly become
synonymous with your actual friends like
that that whole we're gonna miss you
it's like you know you're sitting right
here and it's like no on this screen
we're gonna miss you it's it's so messed
up and I think that there is actually a
strange difference and it's it's sort of
generational as well where people like
Gary and I who sort of came into the
internet before Facebook see you know
you mentioned like catching up with old
friends and like all this I did people
who are coming into Facebook now never
had the idea of ever losing touch with
old friends like to them it is
synonymous for their social graph and in
fact there are a lot of friends who
they've never met and that's what's
that's what to me is slightly strange
about Facebook and is is potentially
really interesting but potentially
really damaging to social relationships
is this idea that oh because I've like
poked them on facebook this week I've
had my interaction quota with them and
yet you never lose touch with anyone
that's great but actually as someone
who's did use Facebook to find a bunch
of old friends I Sonny resident actually
have that much in common with most of
them like having you know having not
seen him since school and we but on
Facebook it almost doesn't matter as
long as they're there and as long as
their picture pops up every so often and
I click or see a picture there I feel
like oh I know them and I worry that
we're gonna end up with fewer real
meaningful relationships and I mean I
don't know 20 years to know we might
just all adjust it and it might be fine
but it's it is a bit worrying when
you're yeah when your only interaction
with somebody's that little picture so
that the idea of missing that avatar is
enough to make you stay on some I think
the flip side is I don't think we ever
had that many meaningful really I don't
see how in any way Facebook is going to
shrink meaningful relationships I think
we lived with a pretty small number of
meaningful relationships I mean there's
Dunbar
numbers and things of that nature I get
that but I think when you really look
you know ice but I do something very
funny when I fly I I like to fly with I
switch seats sometimes and sit with very
old people I feel like they've played
the game and I like to like suck you
know that
you know that knowledge out of them I
think I'm just an old soul I think
people have very small graphs I think
life is kind of pretty basic and I think
the one thing for me and and listen this
comes down to DNA because I'm very
different than let's say my dad right
very different or polar opposites so I
get a good sense of like the other side
you know I like people and I like no to
me a poke is such baloney and I'm with
you on the flip side I feel like that's
a human being that I might have had
double zero
you know Robert Parish like interaction
with my whole life and so maybe just
that little something means something to
me
you know when I open the door for
somebody and and they you know in the
city and they walk through if they turn
back and give me a smile instead of just
walking through that changes the whole
complexity of like the way I feel and I
just wonder I wonder if that's what's
being replicated and some way I'll be
honest with you I think this stuff is
making it more scalable not less
scalable as a lot of people think I
actually agree with you except my
concern is that the and I don't think
yeah I don't thinks about having more
friends I think it's I think the trouble
is does it dilute the interactions you
have with those who would be your core
friends and do you get to the point
where because you have 10,000 people in
because you're on Facebook all day you
feel like like with the charity thing
you feel like I've done my bit for
socializing today and actually you
haven't spoken to another living soul
apart from opening the door for them I
think what's really neat about our
generation is I've been able to live
life enough with and without this stuff
that it's interesting for all the social
everybody knows me is like you know like
I'm social dude I was insanely not
social I was very focused on building my
career I didn't go out with my good
friends I was hustling it blows my mind
how much more social I really am now
because of things like Google Calendar
and like like you know things that can
actually manage relationships like
somebody hitting me up on my wall a
couple times you know squeaky wheel gets
you know the grease kind of thing I'm
dramatically more social because of it
and I think it has an impact